der nietzsche spezialist volker gerhardt
öffnet zusammen mit barbara bleisch die
schatztruhen eines denkenden fantasten
vgh wir haben sieben gehört friedrich
nietzsche hat sich selber als dynamit
bezeichnet er schreibt in seiner
autobiografischen schrift ecce homo ich
bin kein mensch ich bin damit waren
seine gedanken tatsächlich so explosiv
er war mensch das muss man erst mal
festhalten und der ist denke ich auch
als ein großer mensch mit seinen
widersprüchen in die geschichte der
philosophie eingegangen und dieses
unkonventionelle dass gerade in der
ankündigung betont worden ist das würde
uns ja nur auffallen wenn er weil er ein
mensch wird aber dieses dynamit ist
natürlich eine metapher hier sehr gerne
aufgenommen hat andere haben das über
ihn gesagt und er fühlte sich auf diese
weise richtig erkannt vor allem auch
deshalb weil seine zeit ihn nicht
wirklich wahrgenommen hat er wollte
unzeitgemäß sein und da hat sich die
zeit an ihm gerecht und hat ihn
sozusagen ins unverständliche und andere
abgeschoben
aber das hat sich ja dann sehr bald
geändert er ist zu einem der
bedeutendsten denker des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts avanciert ich habe gerade
gesagt er wollte unzeitgemäß sein dass
richter auch einen den titel eines
seiner bücher die unzeitgemäße
betrachtungen ist er denn heute
zeitgemäßer als er damals war ich glaube
dass man das sagen kann allein durch
seine wirkung auf die zeit zunächst
haben die künstler entdeckt auch gerade
die großen maler des 20 jahrhunderts
dann hat er auch auf die musik wird etwa
richard strauss und ist dann auch schon
ab den 20er jahren als philosoph von den
philosophen zunimmt wahrgenommen
wenn man sieht wie verbreitet nietzsches
philosophie auf der ganzen welt ist kein
denker hat so viele ausgaben niemand
wird derzeit so intensiv etwa in china
gelesen wird schon die siebte
übersetzung des zarathustra gemacht dann
muss man sagen hat er offenbar den nerv
der zeit getroffen und insofern kann man
ihn als zeitgemäß ansehen obwohl die
überzeugten die diana sagen dass er
derzeit heute immer noch weit voraus
sie haben gerade china erwähnten sie
haben im vorfeld auch gesagt dass sie
immer wieder einige doktoranden haben
aus china auch aus japan aus korea die
bei ihnen zu nietzsche promovieren wie
kommt das warum interessieren sich die
chinesen und japaner für nietzsche weil
er ein denker der menschheit ist auch
wenn er diesen begriff selbst nicht in
einem menschenrechtlichen sinn verstehen
wollte weil er kulturübergreifend zu
denken versucht und weil er zum beispiel
über schopenhauer aber auch über die
begeisterung für das indische denken
sehr viel asiatisches aufzunehmen
versucht hat und die chinesen zum
beispiel lesen den zarathustra deshalb
mit so großer begeisterung weil hier die
verbindung von literatur dichtung und
denken etwas berührt was sie aus ihrer
eigenen philosophie zum beispiel durch
die tradition des konfuzianismus kennen
und wenn sie jetzt vergleichen mit den
vielen deutschen doktoranden die sie
haben nehmen die den oder die
deutschsprachige nehmen die dann ganz
andere elemente auf bei nietzsche ist
jetzt beispielsweise chinesen und
koreaner tun also da kann ich kein
generelles urteil fällen das ist auch
viel zu sehr vermittelt denke ich durch
die wissenschaftliche welt aber ich
hatte einen chinesischen doktoranden der
inzwischen auch fertig ist er kam nach
deutschland um nietzsche zu widerlegen
von ihm stammt der satz dass wir gott
nicht loswerden so lange wir noch an die
grammatik glauben und dieser student war
davon überzeugt dass dieser
das nicht stimmt und einen solchen
ansatz eine solche intention habe ich in
der tat bei einem deutschen doktoranden
noch nie kennengelernt das lag daran
dass hier eine tiefe überzeugung von der
verwandtschaft der sprachen war und eben
auch der wunsch zu zeigen dass wir von
der grammatik gar nicht loskommen
sollten weil sie eben ein element
allgemeiner verständigung überhaupt ist
und deswegen hat ihn diese these
nietzsches nicht überzeugt und ich hatte
den eindruck dass er vieles
zusammengetragen hat was einen wirklich
an der berechtigung dieser these
nietzsches zweifeln willst sie sind
selber senior professor für praktische
philosophie an der humboldt universität
zu berlin und abend selber eine
unglaubliche fülle und schriften zu
nietzsche verfasst ein buch von ihnen
eine sehr schöne einführung friedrich
nietzsche in der banker im beck verlag
erschienen
darin zeigt das ganze panoptikum von
nietzsches denken nach wie sind sie denn
selber zu nietzsche gekommen was ist
ihre persönliche geschichte mit diesen
philosophen oder gibt es viel zu
erzählen aber ich beschränke mich auf
eine bemerkung ich habe ihn früh gelesen
und war dann der ansicht dass man diesen
denker nicht den seminaren behandeln
sollte er ist kein thema für eine
wissenschaftliche kategoriale behandlung
und man kann so war meine überzeugung
aus ihm auch nicht die geschlossenen
philosophischen seminar fähigen
wissenschafts anerkannten theorien
ziehen aber man müsse ihn lesen um sich
durch ihn provozieren zu lassen und um
auf neues aufmerksam zu machen und diese
meinung habe ich erkannt der 80er jahren
geändert weil ich bestimmte themen sah
den nicht wirklich in der philosophie
beachtet worden die zum beispiel das
problem der macht und dann ist mir klar
geworden das interessanteste
diskussionen über die rolle der
philosophie die zukunft der philosophie
die bedeutung des menschen
im anschluss an nietzsche stattfinden
und dann war der groschen gefallen und
dann
habe ich nicht unglaublich krieges
geschrieben aber doch das eine oder
andere zur nische diskussion beizutragen
versucht tauchen sie ein in die
philosophie von friedrich nietzsche
er ist 18 44 geboren in röcken einen
ostdeutschen dorf er war sohn eines
pfarrers wurde streng katholisch erzogen
und schon ganz früh hat sich eigentlich
sein musisches talent erkenntlich
gezeigt also er hat die musik gemacht er
hat musik gehört er hat auch komponiert
er hat gedichtet er war sehr sehr
talentierten guter schüler und die musik
zieht sich ja durch sein leben wie ein
roter faden die liebe zur musik
wissen sie wir ihn eigentlich daran die
musik herangeführt hat aber seine
eigenen deckung von ihnen nun er hat
schon in der kirche die choräle
geschätzt er war mit der orgel musik
vertraut man muss wissen dass er schon
als sechsjähriger im kreis der familie
und in der kleinstadt naumburg wollte
ein aufruf durch seine ernsthaftigkeit
aufgefallen ist und alle mit stolz in
dieser großen pastorenfamilie aus vater
und mutter waren also super
intelligenten und viele pastoren
versammelt als der kleine pastor gehalt
aber er hat dann insbesondere in den der
gymnasial phase in naumburg im
domgymnasium und dann vor allem auch in
dem berühmten internat in dem er war
sehr viel musikalische kontakte gehabt
und hat dann aber ist deswegen zügig ein
bisschen die die eigentliche
erschließung für die musik ist dann
durch ein erlebnis in leipzig wo er
studiert hat durch das hören der musik
von wagen bekommen
das muss man das sollte man der
gerechtigkeit halber auch sagen dass es
wagner gewesen ist der ihnen zu dieser
begeisterung für die musik gebracht hat
und er hat sofort die verbindung
hergestellt zwischen der musik wagners
und der philosophie schopenhauers und
das ist eben das was ihn dann in den
ersten jahren seiner eigenständigen
philosophischen arbeit stark beschäftigt
er sah in wagner denjenigen der ein
programm der philosophie durch seine
musik erfüllt und zugleich eine
alternative schafft zum bloßen händen
er schreibt ja auch in einem brief
nachdem er zum ersten mal ich glaube die
meistersinger und tristan ouvertüre
gehört hat schreibt er
es zog ihn jede faser im leid wenn er
diese musik hören würde war das in
dieser zeit speziell oder wurde wagner
insgesamt so rezipiert dass die leute
unglaublich begeistert und berührt waren
von seiner musik ja wer sich ihm
überdies und wer etwa die tristan
overture um die es damals auch ging
gehört hat der war angesteckt ich glaube
schon dass das zur frühen wirkung von
wagner auch schon in dresden gehört hat
und insofern ist das kein singuläres
phänomen aber wagner war ja dann aus
deutschland vertrieben
gerade eben auch aufgrund seiner
politischen ansichten auch seine
religionskritischen positionen war ein
anhänger feuerbachs und ist insofern
doch in deutschland erst einmal wenig
zur aufführung gekommen und er hatte
auch nach dem schwachen erfolg seiner
ersten opern wenig resonanz so dass der
erste wird den umweg von paris und dann
die zurückgezogenen jahre in luzern in
trieb sie dann zwar eigentlich in größe
gekommen ist und das war dann eben ein
großer liebhaber seiner musik ludwig der
zweite könig von bayern der ihnen die
möglichkeiten verschafft hat auch in
deutschland wieder im größeren umfang
aufgeführt zu werden
nietzsche selber kommt er mit 24 jahren
als sehr junger professor nach basel
er wird da professor für altphilologie
und diese beziehung zu weiter
intensiviert sich die beiden sehen sich
sehr oft als er geht oft nachts rippchen
besucht da wagners entsteht eine
freundschaft und seine kollegin judith
reker hat jetzt anlässlich dieser
feierlichkeiten zum 200 geburtstag von
richard wagner
dieses haus in tribschen besuchte
zusammen mit dem wagner keiner branche
zukommen und aus diesem film von
christian walther war
sein beitrag ansehen hier in diesem haus
und rippchen war friedrich nietzsche oft
zu besuch bei warten was haben die für
eine beziehung zueinander wer hat
eigentlich wen wundert ja erstmal es war
für mich fast eine familiäre beziehung
die natürlich auch etwas so voll die
polis von nietzsche gegenüber wagen als
auch er war ein bisschen verliebt auch
in die in die cosima wagner aber die
haben natürlich auch ein tiefes
geistiges intellektuelles verhältnis
miteinander gehabt wären gewundert hat
es ist schon eine generation älles
problem war wie ein paar ältere und 30
jahre älter
nietzsche nietzsche widmet wagner sein
erstes werk der geburt der tragödie und
nicht umgekehrt dass ich meinen wagen
wer nicht auf die idee gekommen mit
irgendwas zu so wird man damals aber
sehr bald selber geschaut dass sie auf
augenhöhe mehr oder weniger reden weil
es ja auch sehr schnell erkannt wird von
wagner alles an ihren philosophischen ja
wir haben es gerade gehört der junge
nico widmet seine erste große schrift
zum zur geburt der tragödie
richard wagner wie kommt das nun das ist
die begeisterung durch die musik das
unerhörte angesprochen seien durch eine
völlig neue form des clans und die
parallele zu der philosophie der
nietzsche in jener zeit noch angefangen
hat eben der philosophie schopenhauers
und man muss sagen dass ein autor der
sein buch in seiner vorrede nur einem
einzigen menschen widmet und so tut als
brauche es auch nur diesen einen leser
zu geben vorrede an richard wagner zeigt
die hingebung und zeigt auch die große
erwartung und für ihn ist nach der
vorrede die musik wagners wie er sagt
ein wirbel und wendepunkt
der weltgeschichte er erwartet dass
wagner das was nietzsche im buch
darzustellen versucht nämlich die
bedeutung der tragödie für die kultur
aus dem geiste der musik jetzt wieder
erweckt also wagner ist für ihn der
anfang einer neuen eine chance und
insofern kann man den komponisten und
seine musik gar nicht höher schätzen
aber man muss genau lesen
man muss sehr genau lesen den
schlusssatz dieser vorrede an richard
wagner
der geht darauf aus wagner zu einem
vorkämpfer einer neuen zeit zu erklären
und wenn man sich fragt wagner nur der
vorkämpfer einer neuen zeit dann wird
ganz deutlich der eigentliche kämpfer
der diese neue zeit eröffnet und die
begriffe zur verfügung
das ist für richtig dass man sieht in
diesem buch eine eine wirklich
hingebungsvolle verehrung im zweiten
teil auch wirklich eine darstellung der
musik aus dem geiste der schopenhauers
philosophie und zugleich die erwartung
dass der philosoph dann letztlich den
schritt über die musik hinaus tun muss
was ist denn diese schopenhauer schicken
so wie ich jetzt immer wieder erwähnen
was sind die kernelemente die wagner und
nietzsche in dieser zeit beschäftigen
und akzeptieren auch ich hoffe es
gelingt mir das in wenigen sätzen zu
sagen
schopenhauer geht davon aus dass es eine
grundkraft der welt gibt einen
elementaren trieb den er will nennt und
der ist nicht individualisiert der hat
keine einzelnen teile zerfällt nicht den
einzelnen elemente sondern schafft aus
sich heraus im wollen dass das handeln
leitet das handeln dann das individuelle
menschen und der vorstellung überhaupt
erst die welt der erscheinungen und wir
leben als menschen in dieser welt der
erscheinung
sind darin aber letztlich gefangen im
gefängnis das prinzip ium individuation
ist also wir sind als individuen stoßen
wir immer auf grenzen und letztlich
wollen wir grenzenlos sein und schuppen
haus philosophie verspricht
gewissermaßen im tod wieder
zurückzugehen in die urkraft des einen
der welt und in seiner ästhetik gibt es
eine form menschlicher produktivität die
etwas von dieser uhr kraft des willens
im leben selbst spüren lässt
und das ist die musik und insofern ist
wagner derjenige der die musik
tatsächlich so umsetzen kann und so
erlebbar macht dass man noch im leben
selbst die ahnung haben kann wieder mit
dem uhr ein zu verschmelzen und diese
kräfte dienst im leben am treiben die
deutschen noch einmal neu er spricht vom
apollinischen und vom dionysischen das
sind diese beiden prinzipien in diesem
buch geburt tragödie die unser leben
durchziehen die kunst durchziehen und in
der musik auch vorkommen der musik in
eine schöne art und weise verbunden
werden miteinander was sind diese beiden
kräfte napoli nicht wie sich das ist
eine recht originelle erfindung
nietzsches die nietzsche philologen
versuchen immer noch spuren aufzutreiben
für diese unterschiede die sind auch
tatsächlich in der romantischen kunst
gemacht aber so wie ich es verstanden
hat muss man sagen ist das eine ganz
originelle leistung und der sieht in der
griechischen kultur einen kampf dieser
beiden prinzipien die er mit den göttern
apollo und dionysos verbindet und um es
kurz zu machen der erste der dieses
individuelle prinzip künstlerisch
produktiv macht und damit eine ganze
welt schafft ist für ihn mehr
und wieder ist in diesem punkt auch
ebenfalls sehr eigenständig in dem er
der romer forschen seines jahrhunderts
wieder spricht und sagt ein solches werk
von einer solchen einheit sowohl in der
odyssee wie auch in der ilias kann nur
von einem großen individuum gemacht
werden und deswegen ist romer sein
derjenige der eine kultur erschafft und
dagegen ist dann das dionysische also
harmlos gesagt ist dionysos der gott des
weins der trunkenheit des rausches
während das apollinischen der klare
verständige traum ist der dies alles
immer wieder als widersacher zerstört
noch diese art und weise könnte man
sagen ist nietzsche ein dialektiker des
anschaulichen und er beschreibt wie die
griechische kultur sich in diesem kampf
der beiden gegensätzlichen prinzipien
entwickelt und darin zu ihrer größe
kommt und das große trauerspiel am ende
ist das dann ein philosoph auftritt der
versuchte das ganze zu zerstören und
dass es zu kaltes da kommt der nische zu
seiner mich immer noch empörenden
einschätzung des sokrates aber man muss
das vor dem hintergrund dieser auf
gipfeln dialektik von apoll und dionysos
verstehen und das hat an der tiefe
bedeutung bis ans lebensende bis zum
ende des bewussten schaffens bei
nietzsche gibt es irgend ein beispiel
was sie machen könnten wenn sie so rum
gucken in ihrem eigenen leben im leben
der menschen wo sehen wir diese beiden
prinzipien diese kräfte das apolitische
als die kraft des bildlichen ist
gebunden an das begriffliche und wir
können alles was der verstand und was
die vernunft im begreifen schaffen
die ordnung die sie herstellen und die
konsequenzen die sie daraus ziehen in
verbindung auch mit der moral als ein
ergebnis der apollinischen produktivität
sie hin und das wird dann auch in seine
eigenheit durchaus geschätzt aber es
wird nach nietzsche außerordentlich viel
dabei vergessen nämlich die elementaren
triebkräfte des mensch
die immer wieder sich aufbäumen gegen
das was das apollinischen anordnung
verordnet und deswegen die urgewalt das
alles zerreißen dämonischen vor allen
dingen auch durch einen wilden sex
angetriebenen gottes und wenn sie nach
einer veranschaulichung fragen wir sehen
in der tag diesen gegensatz von sagen
wir verstand und gefühl
natürlich in der welt der menschlichen
kultur überall und das glückliche leben
vereint die beiden kräfte also wenn ihr
jetzt einen mönch haben der ganz
politisch lebt auf der anderen seite ein
mensch den sie ausschweifendes leben
lebt fallen sich dem rausch hin gibt
sind diese beiden lebensformen für
nietzsche nicht so gut wie die
lebensform das verbindet ich sehe bei
nietzsche als wesentliches moment die
anerkennung von individualität
also jeder der seine form des lebens
findet ist natürlich dann auch in der
lage zu seinem glück zu finden
aber es ist sicher so dass man dieses
glück nicht findet in einer radikal
entschiedenen einseitigkeit die
lebenskräfte verleugnet und insofern
hätte er sicherlich starke bedenken auch
durch seine spätere kritik am
asketischen ideal den männlich wirklich
für glücksfee ich zu halten aber es gibt
bei ihm die schilderung etwa das
eremiten zu beginn des zarathustra der
eben seine welt verschlossenheit denn
seine ahnungslosigkeit über das was in
der welt vorgeht auch weil er gar nicht
mitkriegt dass gott tot ist sich für
glücklich hält aber das glück ist bei
nietzsche etwas das ich eigentlich nur
im schaffen
ereignen kann und es gibt eigentlich nur
dort eine starke beschreibung des glücks
was versprochen wird
das ist in der kunst erfolg nietzsche
und wagner haben eine sehr
spannungsreiche beziehung nach sehr
guten sehr freundschaftlichen jahren
besucht zb wagner auch sehr oft an
weihnachten er ist auch sehr nahe
befreundet mit cosima wagner die frau
von richard wagner
aber es kommt zum zerwürfnis was sind
die eigentlichen streitpunkte zwischen
den beiden
ich sehe dass daran nicht dass gerade
schon mit hinweis auf den letzten satz
der vorrede an richard wagner gesehen
habe dass letztlich hier zwei
außerordentlich starke persönlichkeiten
mit einem willen zur gestaltung der
zukunft aufeinander treffen und der eine
erwartet dass der andere in dient wagner
hat gleich gesehen dass nietzsche in
seiner unerhörten schriftstellerischen
potenz ein propagandist für bayreuth
werden könnte und insofern hat er ihn
wirklich auch geschätzt und hat darauf
gesetzt dass es eine zusammenarbeit gibt
nietzsche wäre niemals in der lage
gewesen nur ein vorbote für bayreuth zu
sein und insofern war dieser konflikt
schon ursprünglich angelegt also
persönlicher hahnenkampf das würde ich
sagen so kann es nur eine schweiz hatten
um das so verniedlichen das ist kein
kampf an einem kurs in neu gewesen darum
ging jetzt sicherlich nebenbei auch
sondern es geht tatsächlich um größe und
die erwartung der anleitung des
übergangs zu einer neuen kultur
derjenige der wirklich schafft das was
für mich wichtig weil die selbst über
der gegenwart zu leisten das konnte aus
seiner sicht dann letztlich doch nur der
philosoph tun und die musik konnte
vorbereiten und verwahrten dass er das
ganze umgekehrt aus also insofern hat es
da einen einen ursprünglich angelegt
konflikt in der so würde ich statt
hahnenkampf sagen der größe der beiden
figuren und auch die größe ihrer
leistung und das ist dann zum bruch
gekommen nachdem nietzsche das erste mal
bei den proben in bayreuth war hatte
gerade eine großartige betrachtung die
vierte und zeitgemäße betrachtung über
wagner überrollt geschrieben aber er
selbst wollte in bayreuth nicht sein
dass hielt er nicht aus das war eben
auch viel zu viel konzentration auf den
meister und insofern hat er sich dann
von ihnen abgesetzt und man muss dazu
sagen das ist dann auch eine
umorientierung bei nietzsche gewesen er
hat in der dritten und zeitgemäßen
betrachtung über schopenhauer als jetzt
hier wird zu sagen seinen schlusspunkt
mit schopenhauer gemacht ihn noch einmal
gerühmt und ist dann hat abschied
genommen von dem pessimismus seiner
philosophie und hat dann eine phase des
aufgeklärten aufklärerischen denkens
gehabt ein gewisser abschied ein
teilweise abschied von der romantik oder
dem menschliches allzumenschliches der
morgenröte in der fröhlichen
wissenschaft tatsächlich in einer
rationaleren weise philosophiert und da
muss man sagen hatte war sicherlich auch
gute gründe um vorbehalte zu haben
also neben dieser persönlichen spannung
zwischen den eigenen dieser geschichte
mit schopenhauer das nietzsche sich von
schopenhauer er dann abwendet gibt es ja
noch glaube ich im dritten streitpunkt
den sie im vorgespräch mit mir erwähnt
haben nämlich das sagen dass wir stark
sein gewissen nationalsozialismus ein
nationalismus auszuprägen beginnt
während dessen sie zumindest nietzsche
aus einen europäer lesen inwiefern war
nietzsche europäer also ich lege auch
immer großen wert darauf das lied seiner
eigenen leser hat und dass jeder seine
eigene lesart hatte ich denke bei allem
streit und die auslegung nietzsches in
diesem punkt
wir alle nur einer meinung sein dass er
nicht nationalistisch machen und dass es
für uns auch heute immer noch etwas
verletzendes hat zu hören was über die
deutschen sagt und er wollte ein guter
europäer sein und hat den geist europas
schon in dieser sache eher aufgeklärten
phase gedacht da ist wollte er für ihn
die leitfiguren da sagt er kenntnis
reiches tiefes und eben auch sehr an
erkenntnisse bei der kart forciert die
beschäftigung mit der europäischen
moralist ich also es gibt hier schon
sehr gute gründe auch sachliche art wie
sie als jemand an zu sehen der in diesem
punkt völlig befreien wollte von der
kleinkariertheit des nationalen denkens
und für ihn war das ist der zeitpunkt
das denen sie gefragt haben es
unerträglich
dieses geistige volk dass ein so starkes
logische chemie hat dem europa und die
kultur so viel verdankt sie den juden in
dieser form von wagner kritisiert und
abgelehnt wird und er hat bis in die
letzten notizen zu wagner immer wieder
nur den kopf geschüttelt wie dieser doch
große komponist das hat er stets
anerkannt dieser große komponist so
klein sein konnte in seinen politischen
urteil über die
europa steckt in einer krise das ließ
man dauernd das transportieren
nachrichten kann in der krise europas
nietzsche irgendwie von bedeutung werden
ich denke schon dass er das kann erstens
dadurch dass er uns und jetzt ist das
keine bosheit wenn ich das sage wie
sokrates klar macht oder aber auch wie
kant klar macht dass großes denken aus
der krise stand das ist doch ohnehin
schon sozusagen die geburt der
philosophie aus dem geiste des
griechischen konflikt der zerstörung der
alten traditionellen ordnung und eben
dem versuch neue werte neue tugenden zu
schaffen
und da ist es sicherlich nicht so dass
nietzsche in seinem versuch einer
umwertung der werte uns nun im gleichen
sinne tugenden und ziele vorgibt aber
überhaupt wie das vorhin schon im
vorspann ist unkonventionell zu denken
anders zu denken und vor allen dingen
eigenständig zu denken
souverän zu sein und nicht nachzulassen
von den kleinlichen vorlieben für das
gewohnte abzulassen
das sind dinge die man will ich glaube
gerade unter den bedingungen der
europäischen krise gut nutzen sollte und
das ist auch ein punkt nische wird in
italien und in frankreich eigentlich
intensiver gelesen als bei uns und es
gibt viele die in russland
nietzsche lesen also er ist tatsächlich
auch ein anerkannter europäischer denker
und deswegen meine ich schon tun wir gut
daran auch auf ihn zu setzen wir davon
ausgehen dass europa unter diesen
kleinlichen bedingungen einer
finanzkrise nicht untergehen darf jetzt
sind wir schon an der schwelle sozusagen
zum neuen thema wir haben
die musik gesprochen jetzt für die
politik sprechen wir über nietzsche aus
kritiker aus religionskritiker auf moral
kritiker sie haben schon mal erwähnt nie
gesagt gott ist tot was ist da genau tod
oder was meint mit diesen ausspruch das
wüsste ich auch gerne das wüsste ich
auch gerne ist aus seiner herkunft die
sie eingangs erwähnt haben aus dem
pfarrhaus und seiner vertrautheit mit
der geschichte der religion das erste
semester in bonn hat der theologie
studiert also er war nicht nur mit sechs
der kleine herr pastor sondern er hatte
ein ganz starkes religiöses interesse
und das bestimmt auch seine
auseinandersetzung mit den griechen er
ist aus meiner sicht derjenige der nach
hegel und könnte auch noch sagen nach
schleiermacher und auch nach feuerbach
eigentlich das tiefste verständnis für
die religion gehabt hat und deswegen ist
seine religionskritik auch so ungeheuer
wichtig weil er uns insbesondere in
jenem berühmten aphorismus 125 der
fröhlichen wissenschaft durch einen
narren vor augen führen lässt was wir
alles verlieren wenn wir nicht mehr an
gott glauben können wenn wir wie es dann
dort heißt der name sagt das so gott tot
ist als könnte er sozusagen sterben wie
ein großes tier also das ist erst einmal
ein großartiges nachempfinden schildern
und begreifen der bedeutung gottes für
die lebensführung und für die welt
orientierung des menschen
aber interessanterweise würde man ja
erwarten dass das anlass ist zur trauer
also insofern wie es bei anderen
philosophen passiert anlass zu
pessimismus bei nietzsche ist das ja
nicht so sich eigentlich anlass um was
neues entstehen zu lassen bis hin zu
einer lebensbejahung bis hin zu einem
optimismus fast schon
ja das ist richtig und deswegen ist es
gut dass sie mich so fragen denn jetzt
kann ich den zweiten teil meiner
wort geben ich bin ja gerade nur bis zu
dem punkt gekommen um deutlich zu machen
dass wir uns mit nietzsche als
religionskritiker gerade eben seine
wirkung seiner tiefen sensibilität für
die bedeutung der religion interessieren
müssen er geht davon aus dass der mensch
sich letztlich von sich ablenken lässt
wenn er auf gott sieht und gottes willen
zu erfüllen sucht man könnte es kurz
sagen sind für lied ist das phänomen der
entfremdung dass bei maximal so große
rolle gespielt dadurch gegeben dass er
noch an etwas glaubt er seine macht
außerhalb der menschlichen geschichte
und außerhalb der gestaltung seines
eigenen daseins ist und deshalb ist
nietzsche bin bei aller befürchtung dass
der mensch nun nicht mehr weiß was er
tun soll
doch befreit weil eben dieser imperativ
von außen dieser göttliche befehl eben
auch ein unendliches leid in die
geschichte gebracht hat dass nun der
mensch in der lage ist sein leben selbst
zu führen und da sind denn die großen
formeln wie ich finde seiner eigenen
moral wo er sagt dass der mensch
souverän werden soll dass er sein
eigener herr sein sollen dass er die
freiheit und macht aus der eigenen
kompetenz des versprechen dürfens
entwickeln kann
also es geht nietzsche tatsächlich in
diesem punkt um so etwas was man früher
emanzipation nannte der mensch muss sich
von der fremden macht des göttlichen die
für nietzsche ist ein punkt wo ich das
nicht teil aber ich sag das jetzt
einfach weil das verhindern zusammenhang
ist auch von der macht der wahrheit und
der abstrakten macht hätten der
wissenschaft und auch wie ich glaube der
technik befreit um zum eigenen zu finden
nun wirklich der schöpfer seines eigenen
daseins seiner eigenen werte zu werden
und damit wirklich
eigenständig zu sein und das erklärt
denke ich warum bei ihm diese kritik am
göttlichen mit einer so großen
historischen kulturellen erwartung
verbunden ist wir haben hier einen
hammer liegen weil er in seinem buch
götzen dämmerung den untertitel gegeben
hat wie man mit dem hammer philosophiert
und das kann fast schon dieses sinnbild
auch gelten dafür dass er ja schon stück
weit auch mit brachialen worten
zumindest nämlich mit taten versucht
diese jüdisch christliche moral vor
allem zu zertrümmern ist sehr negativ
zum teil bezüglich dieser jüdisch
christlichen tradition
er sagt zum beispiel auch solche dinge
wie mitleid oder menschenwürde
das seien als ausweg seiner sklaven
berater wird es nur darum gehen dass die
bemitleidenswerten kreaturen die
schwachen eben die versuchen noch nach
oben zu kommen und sich bemitleiden zu
lassen aber eigentlich geht es eben um
die herren moral es geht um die starken
die vorangehen sollen sie herr gerhard
sie sind selber lange zeit mitglied
gewesen des deutschen ethikrates sie
sind ein beratendes mitglied glaube ich
der spd kommission über grundwerte
das heißt ethik werte liegen ihnen am
herzen tut ihnen das nicht ein bisschen
weg oder wie können sie das vereinbaren
in der tat mit nietzsche ungewaschen und
und interpretiert könnte ich in diesem
kontext nicht auftreten hier muss man
wirklich lesen verstehen und zu deuten
versuchen und das wird nicht denke ich
gelingen ohne auch eine entschiedene
kritik an ihm also er ist der große
kritiker der philosophischen tradition
und hat sich nicht gescheut wie ich
finde
sicherlich manches richtige über platten
und so hat das so über kant oder
schleiermacher oder hegel zu sagen aber
muss zugleich auch sagen dass er sie
nicht wirklich dass er ihn nicht
wirklich gerecht geworden ist und
insofern muss es uns möglich sein bei
aller bewunderung für den inits es ihn
auch zu kritisieren
und das fängt an bei seiner sprache
wähle zumacht übermensch das kann man
verstehen dass jemand auf diese art und
weise sozusagen an großartige man ja ich
würde mal sagen werbesprüchen für seine
philosophie umsätze mit er endlich mal
wahrgenommen wird
aber das kann uns in der sache nicht
überzeugen beim hammer ist es so dass
viele ihn so verstehen wie hier dieses
martialische werkstoff zeug das eher
nützlich ist eine nagel einschlagen will
die nietzsche interpreten sagen mit
recht dass nietzsche natürlich nicht nur
den vorschlaghammer und den hammer
dieser größe gemeint hat sondern dass es
darum geht in der götterdämmerung um
götzen auszuhorchen also er erwähnte
auch die stimmgabel und die stimmgabel
oder den aus kulta zions hammer schade
dass wir ihn jetzt hier nicht haben des
arztes der eben klopp wir kennen das am
knie sehen reflex oder der am brustkorb
klopft um zu hören ob da irgendetwas
nicht in ordnung ist
also es ist gerade ein hämmerchen das
auch für die leisen töne empfindlich
macht und auf diese art und weise zu
einer diagnostischen sicherheit kommen
will oder um überhaupt auch auf das zu
kommen was andere nennt geht also das
ist die metaphorik des hammers klingt
martialisch aber man kann sie eben auch
anders sie nicht nur kaputt schlagen
sondern auch abklopfen auf das was noch
bestand haben kennt ja und das soll ja
dann wohl auch bestehen und so würde ich
auch mit vielem umgehen was uns zunächst
mal sehr irritiert die zu dem
martialischen formeln gehört auch diese
unterscheidung zwischen sklaven moral
und herren moral
das mag in der beschreibung
geschichtliche entwicklungen wo die
menschen zunächst mal diszipliniert
werden wieder sieht völlig recht zurecht
dass ethik ein instrument ein
gesellschaftliches instrument es um den
menschen berechenbar zu machen und in
der hand von herrschern oder aber von
priestern das ist eine kritik am
judentum ist das dann tatsächlich nichts
an
was als um die menge und die masse
volkswagen zu machen und seine intention
ist in der kritik in der oft zu scharfen
kritik ist aber seine intention richtig
den menschen davon zu befreien er soll
nicht mehr länger kamel sein
es soll aber auch nicht bloß brüllender
löwe sein und noch immer ich ich rufen
und ich tun sondern soll zugleich auch
kind sein das ist sozusagen die letzte
phase in der er das neue aus sich heraus
mit spontaneität naivität und der
erwartung dass die welt völlig neu vor
einem liegt und alle
gestaltungsmöglichkeiten bietet das ist
eigentlich das ziel der moral kritik und
der in zarathustra
doch das sollte man nicht übersehen in
soest war stark gemachten neuen tugenden
und damit könnte ich auch im nationalen
und deutschen ethikrat auftreten dass es
darum geht gerechtigkeit dass es um
wahrhaftigkeit geht das redlichkeit eine
tugend ist und wenn man das dann sieht
dann muss man auch denke ich bei allen
fragwürdigen aussagen die sich in den
texten finden sagen dass es nicht darum
geht die schwachen zu vernichten sondern
sie sollen sich nur nicht wie die
staaten aufführung aber in antichrist
steht auch menschen liebe heißt
eigentlich die schwachen ich kann es
nicht zitieren herr abzustoßen oder so
etwas ja da gibt es das was schon fällt
das soll man treten
das gehört zu den dingen das ist
wirklich aber im antichristen würde ich
sagen gibt es manche formulierung die
man nicht mehr als so wörtlich abgewogen
ansehen kann
also ich bin der letzte der nietzsches
formulierung in allen punkten verteidigt
das muss man kritisieren aber es ist
immer wieder zu sehen
dass es ihm darum geht eine neue ordnung
zu denken und diese ordnung im hinblick
auf die produktivität die schaffung des
neuen die eroberung neuer mehrere
sozusagen wie kolumbus jetzt nun auch
das neue an das neue zu glauben zu
entdecken zu erfassen und das sind dinge
die man so meine ich tatsächlich mit
blick auf den renaissance is muss ich
halten es für jemanden eben das
wiedergeburt thema stark macht und eben
weiß dass die geschichte lebt aus
erneuerungen dass er dies in seiner zeit
voran bringen wollte allerdings ist es
meines erachtens sehr wichtig dass man
nicht davor zurückschreckt ihn auch zu
kritisieren
er hat das vorgeführt in einer über
scharfen weise gegenüber hegel wie ich
finde
geradezu ahnungslos also darf man auch
mit guter kenntnis nietzsches sagen dass
man ihm in manchen dingen nicht folgt
unser gespräch ist teil der reihe
klassiker reloaded in der wir jeweils
auch mit schulkosten zusammenarbeiten
dieses mal dass die klasse 3 gm von der
kantonsschule heerbrugg und die
schülerin deborah lee richie hat eine
frage für uns und zwar lautet die wie
ist es möglich die christlich
inspirierte moral zu streichen wenn sich
das ganze umfeld nach diesen werten
richtet und diese schon seit ewigkeiten
in uns verankert sind
das ist eine schöne frage aber ich würde
zunächst mal zurück fragen ob die
schülerin wirklich mit blick auf die
weltlage sagen kann dass etwas in
ewigkeiten bestand hat und das auch
tatsächlich die gegenwart
diese werte noch für so überzeugend hält
das ist eine unmögliche aufgabe wäre da
etwas neues an die stelle zu setzen
also die dinge sind relativ und
wesentlich relativer wenn man das so
steigen könnte steigern könnte als in
dieser frage mehr
deswegen ist das meines erachtens
keineswegs aussichtslos
um auf neues zu kommen wenn wir etwa
daran denken welche karriere der werte
toleranz den es in dieser form vorher
nicht gegeben hat in den letzten 300
jahren nach größten schwierigkeiten und
nach bei einer völligen verzicht im
zwanzigsten jahrhundert inzwischen doch
immerhin gemacht hat und das was etwas
ist woran ja auch glauben müssen dann
meine ich sollten wir im hinblick auf
die schaffung neuer werte durchaus
optimistisch sein wird auch das ist
nietzsche kritisch sagen dass er zwar
ein denker der menschheit ist aber nicht
hinreichend gesehen hat dass dieser
begriff der menschheit auch tatsächlich
mit einem pathos erfüllt werden kann so
dass hier die qantas sagt jede einzelne
person so behandeln müssen als habe sie
die menschheit in sich und das ist denke
ich ein pathos der ethik die auch eine
erneuerung und auch erweiterung bringen
könnte und die menschenrechte die nische
leider nicht adäquat eingeschätzt hat
sind etwas von einer bereits erfolgenden
umwertung der werte würde mich nicht
scheuen die im anschluss an diese
durchaus auch im einklang mit einigen
seiner aufgeklärten position auch über
die humanität erschüttern ja ich war ja
ein sehr glücklicher mensch hat schon
sehr früh unter magenschmerzen in der
kopfschmerzen gelitten und er fragt dann
auch in basel nach wo man ihn von seiner
professur entbinden möge dass wir dann
eben auch gewährt mit bedauern aber
beginnt dann eigentlich aus freier
publizist könnte man sagen durch ganz
europa zu reisen und verbringt dann ab
18 79 eigentlich die sommer jeweils in
sils maria dieses maria hat eine
unglaubliche faszination auf nietzsche
was findet er da also die einfache
antwort ist es ist über 6.000 fuß über
bayreuth
ja es ist jedenfalls über richard wagner
aber im ernst es ist
man muss dann nur mal gewesen sein dann
muss man das lieben und es ist eben für
ihn er hat dort eben die höhe geschätzt
das klima er fühlte sich wohl das wäre
die einfachste antwort also er war in
diesen sommermonaten viele seiner
gebrechen los und es hat ihn eben auch
diese grenze zwischen kultur und natur
die grenze der vegetation wenn man das
fag stahel hochgeht dann kommt man
tatsächlich an den rand des der
bewachsenen erde
das hat ihn inspiriert und diese
verbindung von himmel sonne und wasser
die seen sind etwas gewesen was für ihn
ja ein medium seines denkens gewesen ist
und hat lange gesucht der sehr lange
gesucht nach einem ort wo er klare luft
hat wo kein schlechter atem der kultur
ist und das hat er dort oben gefunden
hat auch die damals jedenfalls seiner
meinung nach noch zu findenden einfachen
menschen in dieser weise geschätzen das
immer wieder in dieses kleine häuschen
gegangen hat da in sehr bescheidenen
verhältnissen zur pension belebt und
daraus ist ja heute eben doch ein
wichtiger treffpunkt der nietzsche
interpretation geworden nämlich dass
nietzsche haus und sitzen maria
in dieser zeit entsteht ja eben auch der
pfarrer to store über den jetzt schon
mehrere male gesprochen haben in diesem
samstag geht es ja darum so ein neues
zeitalter einzuläuten dieses zeitalter
des dionysischen dieses zeitalter in dem
eben auch dieser übermensch so stark
wird dieser über mensch bei dem ich auch
darum geht unser eigentliches mensch
sein stück weiter zu überschreiten über
uns hinaus zu wachsen könnte man auch
sagen im moment gibt es gerade eine
debatte über diese google daten brille
mit der man sozusagen nicht nur die welt
sieht wenn man durch blickt sondern
immer auch mit einem kleinen fenster
noch die virtuelle welt mit im blick hat
und im zweiten mai ist in der zeit ein
artikel erschienen von thomas assheuer
der darin schreibt dass es
möglicherweise so sein dass diese google
daten brille eigentlich nietzsches
zarathustra diese idee des übermenschen
vorwegnehme oder jetzt erfülle und
nietzsche eigentlich damit erfüllt wird
ich denke diese ganzen neuerungen der
traum des humanismus ist dass das
eigentliche nietzsche zugrunde gelegt
ist
also ich würde dem auto ich kenne einen
artikel nicht empfehlen einfach den
zarathustra mal gründlich zu lesen und
dann wird er sehen dass das zyniker eine
enge verbindung zwischen wissen
wissenschaft wahrheit und technik gibt
und dass er bei dieser von ihnen
richtigerweise betonten
selbstüberwindung dass es für ihn der
eigentliche topos selbstüberwindung
zuallerletzt um technik geht sondern es
geht um ein moralisches verhältnis
sollen selbst um eine richtige
einschätzung der kräfte um die
überwindung von schwächen und dem
versuch sich unter bedingungen zu
bewegen die eigentlich bisher als
unwirtlich als unkultiviert als völlig
neue unbewohnbar und auch
erkundbar gegolten haben es ist eben
dieses leben in eis und schnee das wird
immer mit einem gewissen heroismus von
nietzsche haus und das ist deswegen
aussage ich selber würde die der technik
viele möglichkeiten einräumen
auch wenn ich diese brille noch nie auf
der nase hatte aber nietzsche selbst
sieht darin vor allem ein verhältnis des
menschen zu sich selbst an fortschritt
in der selbsterkenntnis und der
konzentration seine kräfte auf das ihm
wesentliche und dabei hat er die idee
dass es gelingen müsste rationale
effektive emotionale momente wieder
zusammenzubringen und dafür wäre viel
stärker auch wenn das vielleicht lustig
wird die fähigkeit das neue zu tanzen
das in irgendeiner weise auch zu einer
neuen form des ausdrucks zu bringen und
künstlerisch produktiv zu sein also die
künstler die sich dann im zwanzigsten
jahrhundert picasso gehörte dazu ein auf
nietzsche berufen haben die haben glaube
ich diesen punkt bei nietzsche richtig
erfasst auch gut aus steina glaube es
hat ja sind würde ich nur nicht ganz
richtig der ist nun also auch durch
seine theosophie und die anthroposophie
tatsächlich zu einer bewegenden figur
geworden
der sehr viel von nietzsche er hat ja
auch im nietzsche archiv gearbeitet
aufgenommen und vor allem das deutlich
die größte steiners mitglieder verbunden
hat und wir wissen insbesondere auch
durch die arbeiten von karl pack
pestalozzi in basel wie stark nietzsche
sich an goethe das ist eigentlich die
figur im hintergrund und die lässt
erkennen dass die vision dieses über
menschen ein begriff den wir heute
besser nicht gebrauchen weil er ebenso
stark missbraucht worden ist
dass dies im wesentlichen die
ästhetischen die künstlerischen die
produktiven potenzen im einzelnen
entwickeln sollen ständigen trotzdem
noch eine frage von einer schülerin zu
diesem thema und zwar ist das die frage
von jessica mieter und die schreibt
nietzsches theorie des übermenschen
funktioniert doch nur wenn nur einzelne
soliden sobald alle das ideal des
übermenschen verfolgen würden gewiss
riesige konflikte wie stellte sich
dieses zusammenleben vor
gute frage das ist eine sehr gute frage
nietzsche es tatsächlich in seiner
vision zunächst mal auf den einzelnen
konzentriert das geht um zarathustra der
ist auf diese art und weise immerhin als
eine vision vor sich hat wie ein neues
leben aussuchen aussehen könnte und wie
man sich dafür entscheiden könnte
und die große wanderschaft zarathustras
nach dieser einsicht ist ja bestimmt
dadurch gefährten und freunde zu finden
und er findet sie nicht also es gibt
immer wieder zuhörer aber wir haben am
ende nicht den eindruck dass zarathustra
tatsächlich verstanden worden ist und
nun eben auf eine gemeinde blicken
könnte und insofern ist das denke ich
auch eine böse ahnung die nietzsche
hatte dass er in seinem eigenen anspruch
vielleicht nicht wirklich verstanden
werden könnte der untertitel sagt das ja
auch schon zeit also für alle und keinen
aber der anspruch dass es viele erreicht
er bleibt gleichwohl und manager zum
beispiel in einer wirklich unerhörte
provokation meint also sprach
zarathustra könne wie das neue testament
die menschheit und die weltgeschichte in
zwei hälften zu trennen dann sieht man
welche große erwartungen
so wie das neue testament das evangelium
sein eine neue zeitrechnung die stunde
null wird sozusagen wieder eingesetzt
heraufbeschwören könnte so solche
hoffnungen hat er mit dem fahrrad bus
tram und es ist gänzlich auf gänzlich
offen ob daraus etwas werden könnte dass
diese vielfalt der befreiten sozusagen
global auch zu einer einheit bringen
könnte jedenfalls das was nietzsche im
status als eine utopie andeutet das
paradies im schatten der schwerter das
kann uns heute nur einsetzen die
schwerter gehören ins museum
eigentlich finde ich auch wahnsinnig
interessant dass eben ein so
schrecklicher mensch der dann
schlussendlich auch die 89 einen ersten
zusammenbruch erleidet und in geistiger
umnachtung sterben wird also er habe die
letzten jahre seines lebens auch dann
überhaupt nicht mehr schreiben kann
nicht mehr arbeiten können er war
wirklich krank dass gerade so ein
philosoph dieses ideal des übermenschen
zu stark macht könnte man nicht sagen da
steckt schon fast zum psychogramm
dahinter dass er versucht mit diesem
über menschen etwas zu kompensieren
seines eigenen gesundheitszustandes der
nicht gerade der beste war
ja sie haben vorhin schon erwähnt darauf
bin ich nicht eingegangen das ist
zunächst mal ein zeichen auch wirklich
beachtlicher selbstüberwindung wie
nietzsche mit seiner krankheit umgeht
die krankheit gehört für ihn zum leben
und er ist immer dankbar für die
überwundenen phasen der krankheit weil
sie ihm einsicht neue erkenntnisse und
neue entwicklungsstufe gebracht hat auch
richard wagner schätzt der einen die
eine große heilsame krankheit seinem
leben die ihn dann auch wiederum zu sich
selbst befreit hat also da gibt es einen
sehr wachen
umgang mit der eigenen krankheit und der
krankheit überhaupt sie gehört zum leben
und nietzsche versucht sie zu
integrieren
deswegen ist das keine schönwetter
philosophie das muss man wirklich sagen
er versucht gerade auch das tragische
momente des lebens auf das leiden an
sich mit aufzunehmen also daraus kann
man keinen einwand gegen seine
philosophie machen was nicht den
übermenschen betrifft ich würde so gerne
ich ihnen recht geben würde das nicht
vermuten dass da jetzt jemand von einer
krankheit ablenken das ist viel zu ernst
in diesen moralischen anspruch einer
ethisch moralischen anspruch einer
weiterentwicklung des menschen zu einer
neuen form künstlerischer kultur gedacht
als dass das jetzt sozusagen ein moment
ablenken der selbsttherapie wäre man
sieht allerdings dass nietzsche im
letzten jahr des bewussten schaffens
also gegen ende von 1888 insbesondere in
mexiko mo eben manchmal doch
schwierigkeiten hat seine kräfte
realistisch einzuschätzen und da ist er
doch verzweifelt darüber und ich
verstehe das denn so produktiver und
außergewöhnlicher und über sein
jahrhundert wirklich hinaus denkender
mensch wird von seinerzeit nicht
beachtet und dieses leiden eine
missachtung der anderen lässt ihn dann
zur wartung formulierung kommen die dann
seine größe sozusagen eine manifesten
weise gleichsam mit dem hammer vorführen
soll das sind natürlich vorboten der
krankheit voll kg hat sie haben mir
verraten dass sie an einem buch
schreiben nämlich an einer theologie ich
bin sehr gespannt darauf jetzt nach
diesem gespräch sie als nietzsche fan
fast schon auf nietzsche kenner auch auf
ground kenner schreiben eine theologie
ich bin gespannt und ich danke ihnen
sehr für dieses gespräch ich danke auch
sehr für das gespräch
[Musik]